ever since the capitol hill riot of
early january
several congressional hearings have
analyzed what exactly happened
and what happened to the security that
had been assumed to be in place
one of the many questions once it was
clear the capital was being stormed
why did it take so long to call for the
deployment of the national guard
on wednesday donald trump's defense
secretary suggested he was worried that
if
troops were called in there'd be
confusion as to
which side they were on congress or the
rioters
i want to remind you and the american
public that during that time there was
irresponsible commentary by the media
about a possible military coup where
that advisers the president were
advocating the declaration of martial
law we're going to the capitol
miller has contended that trump's
election fraud claims did contribute to
the riot
yet elsewhere on capitol hill the number
three republican in the house liz
cheney was being kicked out of her
leadership position by members of her
party
for her failure to back exactly that
claim
she vowed revenge i will do
everything i can to ensure that
the former president never again gets
anywhere near the oval office
the storming of the capital has focused
attention on the threat of white
supremacy in the u.s
for years federal agencies have warned
that it was right-wing groups that posed
the biggest domestic terror threat
yet money and resources were funneled
instead into surveilling and arresting
racial minorities and those fighting for
civil liberties
the biden administration has promised a
recalibration
this is still your assessment of white
supremacist
extremists are the most lethal threat
we face in the homeland today
mr chairman i do believe that the
intelligence reflects the fact that uh
indeed that
is the case do you agree i do and that's
the
most recent assessment of the fbi civil
rights groups welcome the change of
focus
but are concerned that it will be used
to expand current laws that already
allow for widespread surveillance of u.s
citizens
and to create new domestic terrorism
designations
and databases we're worried that
the reaction is going to entrench
frameworks that have been used against
black and ground communities and
there's not going to be a prioritization
of white nationalist violence in the way
that we think
is necessary that the trump supporters
were planning something significant on
capitol hill had been telegraphed for
weeks
if not months on social media there was
no need for any extra
domestic surveillance yet civil
liberties groups fear
that the riots that ensued will now be
used as a pretext
for even deeper supervision of the views
of all u.s citizens
shia britancy al jazeera capitol hill